these people endure a level of suffering
that is difficult to imagine
most old and many have emotional or
psychological problems
their families live far away or fled the
fighting months ago
they Brave the shelling to come here for
soup and to charge their phones
Russia's bombardment of Bahamut is
getting heavier by the day
my neighbor was killed in her Cellar she
burned alive I fled my home four days
ago during the fighting I had to crawl
along the street to escape there was an
explosion just meters away from me
to destroyed Central town is almost
completely deserted Russian forces are
only around a kilometer away the
artillery explosions are relentless
some people wait patiently in the cold
whisking their lives desperate for food
and humanitarian Aid
others are so hungry they seem oblivious
to the danger of Simply standing outside
I cannot get all the aid I need without
documents and they all burned when my
house was hit on the other side of the
river
many of the people here on the western
side of town are going to food
distribution centers and these makeshift
shops we understand that the majority of
the heaviest fighting is the north the
East and increasingly the southeast of
the city
but of course there is nowhere safe in
Bahamut
most of the people who lived in these
Flats have fled
retired engineer Victor Casino leads us
upstairs
he and his wife Galena and mother-in-law
are the only people left in their
apartment block
93 year old Maria lies wrapped under
blankets in the dark
frail and afraid she wants to see her
son but he lives across the front line
in russian-occupied territory
my life was good before the war she says
we built a nice house we had everything
but then the fighting started
what
picture shows us where they store rain
water for drinking there's been no water
or electricity in bakward for months
he worked in the oil industry for 25
years before the breakup of the Soviet
Union and so is entitled to a Russian
pension
I know if there was a corridor to where
my brother-in-law lives then we would
try to leave or if we could get to
Moscow or St Petersburg where our sons
live but we don't have any money because
we can't get our Russian pensions
anymore
not
most people stopped living above ground
months ago
lude Miller and five other people are
Sheltering in this basement
the shelling has got much worse in the
last couple of days I'm too afraid to
leave the cellar I Preston promised that
he would liberate donbass by new year
but it never happened
life before the war is nothing but a
memory for these people
surviving the nightmare inflicted on
them is all they can hope for now
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera